liberal magazine the Atlantic
questioning why Democrats keep falling
for Superstar losers Stacy Abrams and
Beto O'Rourke who seemed like they
couldn't even get elected dog catcher
both campaigns are on track to get
crushed in their midterm races despite
their campaigns raising 170 million
dollars to unseat Republican governors
in Georgia and Texas but it's really no
wonder with moments like this so I'm
here at the dentist and we're going to
continue our series on the people of the
Border I'm not able to stand on the bar
next door because the ceiling is too low
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all for welcoming us here
today to Ohio that I'm running to serve
you as the next president of the United
States of America I'm looking forward to
celebrating a victory on the 6th of
November I'm running for governor and I
want to tell you why
okay he's running for governor he didn't
tell us why but do you think he has any
good ideas other than hell yeah we're
going to take your AR-15 his only idea
is to turn campaigning into a career and
then live off the millions of the
donations it's a weird world where you
can lose in a race for Congress and it
doesn't matter because the next step is
just running for governor beta's done
nothing to work nothing nothing like
real work except make his life free of
work and it doesn't matter I think this
is It's they've turned it's a great scam
is what I'm saying it's a great scam I'm
jealous you don't have to really work
okay all right so Jesse you've got
Stacey Abrams who says I'm not an
election denier but she never conceded
the election okay and yet you've got
people who still give these losers money
why the two favorite presidents of the
Liberals JFK and Barack Obama so they're
trying to recreate that like they think
their franchises let's just do a second
act so the they see state AC she's black
you're the next Barack Obama and you're
a woman let's go or they see Beto
they're like oh you know what he wears a
nice button-down shirt and college girls
like a smile Camelot here we go here's a
hundred million dollars it doesn't work
like that you can't be a liberal and win
in Texas or Georgia you can be a normal
Democrat maybe have a shot but you can't
be radical left all right Jessica what
do you think of people like Beto who's
married to bait or whatever his name is
who's married to a wealthy woman and you
know hasn't had a real job just like
fetterman well I mean his parents are
paying for him too what's with it
fedo was a congressman which is a real
job last time yeah how long did he have
it a few I don't know how many years all
right anyway for president so as the
only person who actually donates to
Democrats here I'll tell you so I'll go
on like act blue right and I'll look at
all the names and then I'll try to find
the most boring person and my dad had
loved the unsexiest candidate ever
Michael Bennett for president he was
probably the only person donating he was
like this is the kind of person who will
bore you to death but he will be good
and he will be measured and he will get
things done and he kept giving him and
obviously he lost but you should not
fall for these kinds of things and I
wonder with things like Sherry Beasley
for instance in North Carolina or I
don't think the Alabama's would have won
but there are people that you can find
who are also fun and interesting who
have a shot at winning their races and
give them money all right there's a
direct correlation between big fancy
beautiful cover story in a magazine and
failure on a Statewide race and one of
the things that's happening especially
with these two is that they're dragging
down all of the down ballot races we
talked to Henry Cuellar today on
America's yeah and I asked I said do you
think Beto's helping you he didn't say
no but he didn't say yes you tried to
walk a line he knows it's not helping
him and we know from anecdotal evidence
and also data that Stacy Abrams is
dragging down Rafael Warnock right and
so from a republican perspective they
would say did the Democrats just keep on
keep on doing it that's because you fall
they fall in love so easily yep